welcome back to America's favorite game
shell girl on a dirty sweatshirt reviews
adults who have put among times more
effort into their clothing nobody wins
nobody wins nobody would know hi my name
is Grace help me if you don't know know
you know your life is different now I'm
sitting on the floor really trying to
feel like a youtuber you guys which one
of us do you think it's pissed on more
my parents watch my videos let's do it
SAG Awards happen Screen Actors Guild
and that's all I know about that I'm
tired already it looked like I just
escaped from being kidnapped better sure
so the SAG Awards happened a lot of
people attended when I was going through
and choosing photos I did not recognize
like 90% of the actors that make up the
guild for the screen caveat as always I
will likely pronounce names wrong I will
probably mention someone you didn't want
me to I will probably forget to mention
someone that you really wanted me to the
only prescription I have for these
symptoms if they're bothering you is to
eat a dick all right let's get into it
Emily Blunt you look like a beautiful
vagina voluptuous Oh tight glowy
pink emotionless waiting for someone to
take care the only blood always looks
amazing she can wear a full vagina
cosplay costume and still look
absolutely gorgeous John Krasinski's
really getting that [ __ ] she looks like
a cooter cute Emma Stone Oh who's still
your sleeve wow it's like a stepmom it's
also like a pit boss at a poker table
that's like here to him play you got in
a bar fight and like someone hold her
back so hard they ripped off her left
sleeve but you know what she's gonna
keep her cool cuz she doesn't want to
ruin her relationship with her stepkids
it's already on rocky ground to begin
with this is the only person other than
Best Buy employees that should be
wearing pleated pants cute Rachel
Brosnahan you look like a delicate
little doll like a beauty pageant whose
mom is trying to coach her offstage and
arms are not been or like you tried to
Nair your armpit hair before the event
like something went real wrong so you
got like rashes under there so you're
like really trying to conceal them but
so didn't you oh yeah Amy Adams Oh max
one goes to prom like a big black
scrunchie and then a long skirt that
songs my cake you Lupita nyong I don't
how to say her name guys I don't know
how to say her name Nyong'o Lupita and
young I don't know but I know that she's
rad as it's like you put your legs in
jail and your top half is the warden and
they get to decide when they get to go
on parole you margot robbie america's
australian sweetheart this is very
pretty
I have nothing comedic Lee to say about
this other than like Rumpelstiltskin
started to spin your tits and gold and
then just kind of got a little like
budget-conscious towards the rest of the
dress so little bits here and there
government shut down
I made no sense q Chris Pine you've got
Colonel Sanders got hired as a valet for
the night we love a man that can wear
many hats cute chadwick boseman ah yes
this is very good I don't know if that's
like leaves or Paisley's oxtails rat
tails on his jacket but he makes it look
good oh dang it
yeah Catherine zeta-jones whoa whoa
Aquaman
eat your heart out this looks like a
tsunami just washed up on the shores of
Jones Beach jus anymore Oh soda more
soda more soda more this feels very 80s
very like I'm looking for someone at the
law firms office Christmas party in the
80s vibe yeah Michael B Jordan what is
happening did you just era shoot out of
like a Lisa Frank folder this is like at
that store Lela Rose or whatever got
into like EDM do timothy shell ma stop
it I want to wear that oh sorry I just
had an unintentional Hannibal Lecter
moment I have a difficult time reviewing
because of feelings and things and
attractions and stuff science you look
great you angela bassett am
what are these pants cute those are
pants cuz it looks like one of those
dresses you buy at Costco or Sam's Club
that starts out like a teeny tiny little
accordion and then all of a sudden it's
a full size shirt and if they make them
in jumpsuit form now I'm gonna lose my
mind what is this why did it wow you
went to Michael's you bought out the
Martha Stewart party supply section and
you just put on your body you call it a
goddamn day oh you are crafty as heck
you are crafty as heck you Constance
whoo
I'm wooed by this you look so demure
it's so simple and cute and elegant and
you look scared and fragile and
vulnerable and I just want to protect
you somehow even though I know you're
fully capable don't woman you can do
whatever you want I'll see you're
wearing an armband hey ring ring ring
it's the 90s they said good on you Jew
Aaron Chris yeah I see you rod Roddy
cosplaying right now and I fully approve
the price is right I like to showcase
showdown if you want to spend my wheel
okay cute Laverne Cox cats damn it you
always look stunning and it makes me mad
and happy and glad and all of it at once
ah you're not a phoenix rising but not
from like your own ashes like you're
already a phoenix like you're a phoenix
that's rising on top of another
Phoenix's ashes you're just like I don't
I'm I've been like this the whole time
cute Elisabeth Moss you look like a cake
topper this is very pretty you look like
them and then son say yes to the dress
and it's right before they're about to
Jack you up I secretly hope that that's
not like a black belt that that's just
like a censor bar cause she is something
like very politically incorrect written
across her stomach you Jane Fonda's what
how you were gonna you be Aquaman's mom
and you're like I get it and sick of the
fancy foams and the blues and the greens
and you know what a rad mother cute
Alison Brie whoa she's gift-wrapped
she's like a gift sent from heaven psych
hell back death God Wow but they still
give gifts down there cute Lady gaga oh
you look like old Hollywood so demure so
beautiful you also look like you could
be on say yes to the dress but you're
like the after when they go follow up
with them at the wedding and they're all
fully like decked out and this is just
pretty good job Jana Shahidi
whoa this is cool as heck this is like a
RuPaul's Drag Race like reveal outfit
this is seven outfits and one full
spandex bodysuit going on and then you
got lace on top and sequins and what
you're wearing every type of wardrobe
that you could wear to the event all at
once you get to wear pants the whole
time you know shangela oh my
guardzilla this is insane this is like a
snuffleupagus we're on RuPaul's Drag
Race
you took a shag carpet you dip dyed it
you tied it around your waist you put a
corset on and you've made it work I love
it do Kate Nash I don't know what's
going on here but I'm enjoying it this
is like if a six-year-old girl designed
a dress for the red carpet I want to be
pink
I'm a big puppy princess leave a lot of
hearts on it come on glitter viewing out
everywhere I then want to hold up clear
plastic bubble bags you do you know Yee
I don't know how to say this name but
this is absolutely incredible you look
like a bunch of butterflies are having
like Rainbow diarrhea all of your body
and it's absolute singing outstanding
alright that's it for my SAG Awards
fashion review I know I'm a little rusty
on it guys please forgive me if you guys
want me to do other fashion reviews for
red carpet events coming up in the
future leave your suggestions down below
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos whenever
the [ __ ] I want now and pick the belt I
don't know how it works you know other
people say it correct do what they say
but for my channel other than that I
don't know okay ready
don't want this side oh my god do I have
a side in 2019 oh my god